eine dramatische geschichte und jetzt
ist mein kollege jörg völkerling auch
bei dem vater der kleinen mia sophie wir
haben gerade alle die szenen gesehen und
ich glaube jeder kann nachvollziehen
dass man alles versucht um sein eigenes
kind zu retten egal wie gefährlich das
für ein selber ist aber die frage ist
trotzdem denkt man in dem moment
überhaupt darüber nach was das für einen
selber bedeutet jetzt in dieses haus
hinein zu rennen wird diese frage habe
ich auch gestern schon mit michael
scheller der jetzt neben mir steht
gesprochen und er hat mir das
geschildert aber nichts kann einfach das
ersetzen was er selber mitgemacht hat
und michael du hast am samstag durch
einen anruf erfahren es brennt an eurer
straße wie was hast du dann durchgemacht
wie hast du die situation erlebt ich
habe mir anfangs dabei nichts gedacht
was sagt dieser hat in der an nummer 8
und wo mir dann ankommen sind habe ich
unser haushalt in flammen gesehen und
ja ich bin wie gesagt sofort aus dem
auto raus ganz oben wo es gebrannt hat
aber ich bin leider nicht weiterkomme
und
daneben runtergebracht und wie man dann
auf den videos seht was in den internet
kursieren behandelt wie ein
schwerverbrecher
aber wie schon gesagt es kann sich keine
in unserer situation nachvollziehen wie
wir uns fühlen
aber ein vater als schwerverbrecher hin
zu stellen nur weil er seine tochter
retten wollte
mir fehlen die worte tut mir leid
andererseits ging es ja letztlich darum
dass du dich auch nicht selber in gefahr
bringen ist dass du nicht um kommst aber
das hat fertig in der rolle keine keine
rolle geschmack eine frage für dich mein
leben es vollkommen egal solange das
leben meiner kinder sichert ist aber wie
schon gesagt ich würde auch für die
anderen drei würde ich in mein leben
geben aber das
kann
man nicht nachvollziehen wenn man die
situation nicht erlebt hat also für mich
war einfach kopf aus und durch durch die
mauer
egal was kommt aber
selbst an rettungswagen wurde ich noch
fest kalt nicht durfte nirgendwo hin
ich hab dich ja gestern auch erlebt das
ist ja auch irgendwo irrational ihr
macht euch alle als familie schreckliche
vorwürfe obwohl die überhaupt nichts
dazu könnte oder wie ist das
und ja es ist einfach wenn man als vater
seiner tochter nicht helfen kann ist
deshalb klar jeder vater würde sich dann
die schule geben ich konnte sie nicht
retten aber
letztendlich
ist man halt machtlos wenn da was ich
nicht 89 personen auf einen irgendwo rum
krabbeln und zu boden drücken und dann
stehen noch zehn personen dort und
kommt nirgendwo durch was soll man
machen als einzelner mensch ich meine
hercules bin ich auch noch nicht also
die frage wird ja momentan noch geklärt
von den lka brandsachverständigen die
jetzt heute im aus sind was die ursache
dafür war es gibt gerüchte über offen
liegende leitungen im haus offenbar auch
keine brandmelder in dem haus fakt ist
das löschwasser hat alles zerstört
michael du stehst jetzt ihr habt eure
tochter verloren aber ihr habt doch viel
mehr verloren ihr steht absolut vor dem
nichts wie in welche situation befindet
ihr euch da jetzt das materielle zeug
ist wie schon gesagt das ist mir
eigentlich relativ unwichtig es gibt
viele leute die was man was
vorbeibringen
danke auch an allen aber es wird halt
nie jemand das ersetzen können was man
wirklich verloren hat es materiell ist
kann man immer ersetzen aber das leben
meiner tochter
kann man nicht dass jetzt noch das ist
sich keiner vorstellen
vielen dank seine schwer sehr schwierige
situation auch für mich hier und ich
gebe einfach damit mal zurück nach
berlin zurück vielen dank
natürlich unser ganzes beileid und
tiefes mitgefühl für die familie den
spendenaufruf haben wir gerade gehört
alle informationen dazu auch noch mal
auf bild.de
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren